hello everyone today is the rest day in
the Tata Steel chess tournament so it's
a good opportunity for me to visit some
of your suggestions from the previous
week while I was away in Germany this
game here is probably the second most
requested game the first one was that
Ireland win over Caruana and you all
know that he car Nakamura was visiting
South Africa he played the speed chess
championship finals against Carson in
South South Africa and this is a game he
plays against South African chess
hustler I couldn't find the name of this
person if any of you know his name do
share in the comments I will add it in
the description and I believe the time
format for this game is three minutes
plus one second increment so let's see
this game it's quite a theoretical game
and for those of you who enjoy a good
Italian game it will be quite a treat so
the the the chess hustler opens the game
with E for handicar plays d5 we have
Knight to f3 knight c6 Knight to c3 and
Knight to f6 the four Knights game and
Bishop to c4 going into the Italian game
Bishop to c5 we have d3 castles by both
sides and d6 and I don't know if it's
just me but it seems like the sound of
the pieces has changed especially the
castling sounds might be something with
my speakers but I don't know it sounds
different Bishop to g5 this is still all
theory and h6 we have here and here
White has a couple of options he can
either retreat with the Bishop to h4
maybe the g3 after black pushes g5 or he
can simply capture we have captures
Queen captures and then go 95 Queen back
to d8 defending the c7 pawn and then c3
and it's a it's a perfectly fine
variation for white here The Hustler
decides to go h4 we have Bishop to g4 my
nakamora h3 and now nakamura does what
what white didn't do when he had the
chance
he plays Bishop capture screen captures
and now goes Knight to d4 attacking the
Queen Queen to b1 as the Queen has to
defend the c2 pawn we have g5 Bishop to
g3 and now
see 6 so it's still a pretty equal
position both sides have to be very
careful
tonight the e2 he cargoes came to g7
he's ready to put some rooks behind
those pawns and start pushing on the
Kings side Knight captures the best
characters and c3 Bishop to b6 and King
to h2 by white we had h5 preparing age
for now f3 making room for the bishop on
f2 h4 by Nakamura Bishop to f2 and now
Knight to h5 and here if you look at
this position on Nakamura has a very
firm grip on the f4 squared this Knight
is definitely ready to jump to a4 and
the bishop on f2 is an excellent
defending piece it's defending the g3
square also it's gonna be it's gonna be
a useful defender and here why should
probably play something like d4 and keep
the bishop on f2 but instead the hustle
plays Bishop captures on b6 we have a
capture some b6 this only improves
black's pawn structure and opens up the
a file for Nakamura's rook if needed we
have d4 now and Queen to f6 may be
preparing ideas like Queen to f4 check
coming with the night to g3 and so on so
f4 is played here and instead of this f4
move there really isn't an active move
for white here why it simply has to play
a waiting move such as Bishop to b3
maybe rook to e1 and see what Nakamura's
plans are but he played f4 this does
open up the attack from the Queen to the
night and h5 but this is this isn't
working because night simply captures
and it's a very hard to see what white
wanted to do here maybe this is just a
just a bad call or something because
there's there is no move Nakamura can
make here that would actually be a bad
move other than something like Queen to
f5 given up the Queen but ok Queen to g4
this does activate the White Queen and
here Hikaru plays Queen to g6 unpinning
we have D captors on e5 d captures on e5
and now rook to f2
preparing to double up on the F file
rook a to the 8th now nakamura grabs the
open D file
and we have rook a to f1 now Nakamura
doubles up on the F file and we have b5
taking away the bishop and there really
aren't that many squares for this Bishop
d3 is unavailable e 2 isn't really that
that much of an active square but
whether you go Bishop to e2 or Bishop to
b3 still Nakamura's ideas rook to d2
so Bishop to b3 is played and now rook
to d3 a rook to d3 now rook to f3 and we
have rook F to d8 now nakamura doubles
up on the d file King to g1 and now rook
captures on f3 rod captures and rook to
d2 Hiro Nakamura has a very nice attack
on the G tube on threatening to win the
Queen also he's threatening to win the
b2 pawn so rook to f2 the this is the
only move that really stops both threats
nakamura captures rook captures captures
and here it's a very nice move by
nakamura he played king to h6 although
it seems like nakamura can win some
material with night to d3 after he plays
this night to d3 check after king to g1
and he does grab the pawn on b2 you have
this Queen to d2 move now you do have to
do something about this night if you
play Knight to c4 then white wins back
the pawn if you play Knight to a4 then
white has this Queen to e3 move and this
Knight really doesn't have anywhere to
go
other than b2 but then the Queen will
just attack it again so this doesn't win
a pawn but it's really you know this
place is the knight and the edge of the
board this is not something that Kimura
was interested in doing so after the
skin captures on f2 King to h6 by
Nakamura Queen to f5 offering to
exchange Queens and Nakamura is already
up a pawn here so trade of Queens isn't
isn't that bad for him he plays Queen
captures we have Tong captures and now
King to g7 defending the f7 pawn also
preparing King to have 6 to grab DF 5
pawn we have g3 H captures on g3 team
captures and g3 and King to f6 now and
there really is no point
protecting the f5 bonus you're gonna
lose it anyway batteries to just give up
the pond and grab the f7 pawn if you
play something like Bishop to c2 to try
and protect it you can because Knight to
d5 is coming now the thread is of course
night to e3 to attack the bishop and the
pond so I have to stop this king of
three and now comes Knight East seven
with a double attack on the pawn and
after you defend this with King to g4
now comes Knight to g8 threatening
Knight h6 checking the King kicking him
away from the f5 pawn and then grabbing
the point with the night so this would
be this would be futile so after h4m
Bishop the c2 wasn't an idea here so h4
hustle goes for more active approach we
have G captures on H 14 captures on h4
and now King captures on h5 and Bishop
captures on f7 and it's a it's almost an
equal material nakamura is up a pawn and
he does have BB pawns but this is a
passed pawn and it's it's very hard to
stop this pawn I mean it's impossible to
stop this pawn so Nakamura starts
pushing it efore Bishop to b3 III now
came to g3
kingi for protecting the passed pawn we
have Bishop the c2 check tonight the d3
as you can see the team doesn't really
have a way of approaching of approaching
this position we have a for now but
simply - you can simply disregard
whatever whatever is happening on the
Queen side as this pawn is now becoming
a queen the King still can't approach
the pawn is guarding f1 Knight is
guarding this Square King is guarding f3
so there is a wall here that the white
king cannot approach the passed pawn
bishop capture screen captures and King
to f4 now this is a completely lost
position but Hosler doesn't doesn't want
to resign the game maybe in a Kimura
well blunder or maybe maybe he will lose
some time you know you never know so e1
Queen and the okay now this is set to
auto promotion here my interface
immediately grabs the Queen but in the
game
Nakamura was playing the South African
chess hustler the hustler was holding
the Queen in his hands and Nakamura just
left the pond instead of a queen so here
the hustler played King to f5 and here
Nakamura played pawn to e4 checked
instead of the Queen and here they had a
big argument was it a losing move for
Nakamura was it okay to move upon then
Nakamura said that the rule is if your
opponent is holding the Queen in his
hands that you can actually move the
pawn so I don't know I have no idea what
the rule here is if any of you have any
idea I do share in the comments I'm
pretty sure you cannot move upon for
four squares so but after a two minute
discussion they decided to continue the
game but I will put a deal original link
in the description below if you haven't
seen it feel free to check it out it's
quite quite a brutal game so King to f6
and here you can see Nakamura's
immaculate technique how to checkmate
with the king and queen with a beak
after Sunday for Nakamura grabs the pawn
for some reason King g5 would have Queen
to f3 a la king the king away so the
King can't go anywhere he can only now
use the B the the G and the H file King
g6 we have Queen a 4c for King to e4 c5
the hustlers trying to give up all the
pawns
so maybe maybe he can create a stalemate
King e5 we have King g7 Queen f6 check
King h7 King f5 King to g8 now King to
G's g6 and if only The Hustler didn't
have this b2 pond and then it would be
stalemate but here he is forced to play
b3 or before doesn't really matter he
plays b3 and nakamora plays Queen to g7
and this is checkmate so a great victory
for Nakamura and he really showed how to
play a nice theoretical game and if you
play this opening with black it's it's a
nice game to see but it's interesting it
was this pawn to e4 check move possible
or not Nakamura says it's possible if
your opponent is
holding the Queen in the sands but I
don't think it is either way it wasn't
an official game or anything it was just
for fun so everything goes I guess so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
a lot of you have requested this game I
would like to thank Dom I played pirates
Satish Mahadevan Benny tank and
Christopher kun for a contribution to my
channel think a lot to really appreciate
it as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon